let's go next to steve from chicago
steve welcome you're on the air
hi david
um
i was just wondering um i saw your video
about the um
the decision that was leaked for the
supreme court yes and i know that
towards the end you're kind of talking
about um
next steps what could happen if this
happened
um i kind of i feel like you're usually
pretty rational i kind of felt like your
thought process was
like do you actually think that's
something realistically that would
happen
listen i i did i did a follow-up on
wednesday
where i say i'm not literally claiming
that in the next few months they're
going to try to ban interracial marriage
that's not what i'm saying what i am
saying is you don't stop with one of
your biggest victories and say now we're
satisfied we're not doing anything else
charlie kirk literally said
if you can get rid of roe v wade
anything is possible so even they are
saying it so yes i do think they're
going to try to go further i think it
might be
um gay marriage i think it could be you
know
access to contraception with no co-pays
uh but yes i think they're going to try
to go further
okay i mean i i really don't i mean i'm
not saying that they wouldn't we they
want to go for anything else i just
um don't think i've really seen
much movement of like pushing for like
the getting rid of uh interracial
marriages or okay but i'm not sure steve
are you did you listen to did you hear
what i said
yeah i i heard what you said okay yeah
i'm also agreeing with anything's
possible but i've not seen any movement
in the last few days since the decision
leaked to try to ban interracial
marriage but there's a list of of things
which some of these conservatives are
also against and my view is they're not
going to stop with abortion but i agree
with you in the last four days
they've not said we want to ban
interracial marriage we're on absolutely
the same page steve
no i'm on the same page there i'm saying
also not even counting the past four
days
looking at
what they would like to do i don't think
that's even close to the top of
something that would be within the next
years
or any time like any relevant time you
think they
would you agree that they would gladly
try to get rid of uh
no co-payment access to contraception as
part of obamacare you think that's
something they would want to get rid of
uh i think that would be definitely i
don't
i don't think that's a top list but i
think it's definitely more realistic
than them being like let's get rid of
gay marriage
okay i think i think many of them would
love to get rid of gay marriage but
listen let's just give it time and then
we'll we'll see but i don't think this
is the end let's i'll just put it that
way
okay i i was i just kind of wanted
clarification because i just i maybe i
missed your follow-up it kind of just
sounded that you like thought like
literally next step would you get rid of
like gay marriage and stuff like that
and
didn't seem like there's been any like
major push for that
right uh yeah i gave a list of you know
a half dozen things let's see what they
do next
all right thank you all right there's
steve from chicago one of our sponsors
today is bluechu a unique online service
delivering the same active ingredients
as viagra and cialis in a chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost and
they're giving my audience an entire
month supply for free so if you think
you could benefit from an extra boost of
confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping